all therefore members of the public
following the meeting by the live stream
will be able to see each of us on the
screen individually
please announce yourself by name when
speaking and if you want to refer to
anything in the officer report or
appendices
can you please first clearly state the
relevant page number and paragraph
number thank you all
good afternoon and welcome to watch for
District Council's remote licensing and
appeals subcommittee meeting and welcome
to anyone watching this live via stream
my name is counselor Carol Weston and I
am the chairman of the licensing and
appeals subcommittee the other members
are and if the members would like to
introduce themselves please
Celso Lori Shaw Council Phil Shore and
the committee's League advisor and can
you introduce yourself please Chris yeah
my name is Chris I win and sister here
at Watchers Council thank you the
committee will follow the procedure set
out in the pack you'll note at item
three on the agenda the purpose of the
meeting today is to consider an
application for a premises license made
by red door please could the applicant
introduce himself mr. Lyon I see you
actually introduce yourself please I
only LLC yeah thank you
do you wish to call any witnesses at all
absolutely not
thank you very much please could the
council the licensing officer introduce
themselves good afternoon I'm Stephen
green now I'm the principal
Enochs the watcher district councils and
mr. greener can you also there's no
physical interest parties also as well
on the call is Carisbrooke who is the
licensing officer that works with myself
I'm not aware of any other interested
parties but there is representation from
someone on this video cool no it's not
for me to Courtney witnesses there is no
responsible authorities that is making
representation okay thank you and have
all the parties we see the agenda and
report for today's hearing yes just be
heard okay okay so please can all
qualities be reminded that they have
each had 15 minutes to present their
case
Oh mr. greener can you summarize the
application please sorry I'm we just
need the earth the other interested
party to introduce themselves is that
counselor Mike Wilkinson yes sorry
counselor might real considers you like
to introduce yourself please yeah
Prodigy's Thank You chairman councillor
Wilkinson I am one of the ward
councillors for the ward in which the
Red Door situated and will you be
speaking on this sir I'll be requesting
a chance to speak chairman thank you
okay
Thank You councilman consume back to you
Green place good afternoon
a quick summary of the report if those
okay this report introduces an
application for the grant for premises
license made under Section 17 of the
licensing Act 2003 the application must
be determined within five working days
of the conclusion of the hearing in
accordance with paragraph 26 of the
licensing Act 2003 hearings regulations
2005
the application was submitted to the
licensing authority by malossi leisure
limited on the top of May 2020 and
refers to the premises known as the red
door one free one High Street Braley is
he Appendix A consists of the
application form which has been
circulated appendix B is also a map
locating the site of the premises the
application is for the following
licensable activities within the times
and dates as outlined within the report
it's a live alcohol Monday to Sunday
from 8:00 in the morning until 2:00 the
following morning live music from Monday
to Sunday 8:00 in the morning until 2:30
the following morning recorded music
Monday to Sunday 8 a.m. to 2:30 the
following morning performance of Dance
Monday to Sunday 8 a.m. to 2:30 the
following morning and late-night
refreshment Monday to Sunday from 11
p.m. until 2:00 in the morning
the hours open to the public will be
Monday to Sunday from 8:00 in the
morning until 2:30 in relation to
representation responsible authorities
the application has been assessed by an
environmental health and they are not
making any representation the police
have agreed conditions with the
applicant for the subcommittee to
consider should the license be granted
Appendix C is a copy of the agreed
condition other persons there have been
two representations received from the
local residents the representations
raised concerns in relation to the
following licensing objectives the
vention of crime and disorder public
nuisance and Public Safety an appendix B
consists of a copy of the valid
representation has received all parties
involved have been served with the
relevant notices and documentation
required by paragraph 6 and 7 of the
licensing Act here in regulations 2005
paragraphs eight and nine of the
regulations required that Sparty's
notify the licensing authority no later
than five working days before the
hearing of those matters mentioned in
paragraph 3.1 above and a pro-forma was
sent out with the notices and
determination mentioned in paragraph
three point one one above legal
implications provisions of the licensing
acts 2003 licensing acts 2003 hearings
regulations 2005 guidance issued under
section 182 of the licensing Act 2003
and the raht Judicial Council statement
of licensing policy approved by council
with a period of the 31st of January
2016 through the 31st of January 2021
and needs to be considered by members in
determining the application and equality
impact assessment has been completed and
found no impacts even positive or
negative on protective groups as defined
under the equalities Act 2010 the
recommendation it is proposed to the
subcommittee resolves the determinant of
the application having considered all
representations made at the hearing the
following options are available to the
members to grant the application
subjected to conditions and are
consistent with the operating schedule
modified to such extent as members
considered necessary for the promotion
of the licensing objectives and any
mandatory conditions must be included to
exclude to the scope of the license any
of the licensable activities to which
the application relate free to reject
the application or for subject
paragraphs 1 2 3 of the licensing Act
2003 hearings regulation 2005 who was
during the hearing to a specified state
to arrange for a hearing to be held in
specified additional dates where the
members consider it necessary for the
consideration of any representation or
negative made by a party and that's the
conclusion is the report
Thank You mr. greener members of the
committee
never an opportunity to ask mr. greener
some having clarifications of any
questions if you wished um counselor
mrs. Shaw I've got nothing cut this
follow chair but I might want to come
back thank you okay doctor mr. Shaw
Thank You chair on the part three the
operating schedule obviously the the
premises license to start date is shown
as the first of the fourth twenty is
that going to be altered now yes that
will be following today's hearing in
today's decision thank you and the other
question on item which is page twelve
point four one six which is recorded
music the item actually says myself I
don't know if he was just a typo these
recorded music yet please get further
details here to operate light music
strictly between these times requested
as that just been copied over from I to
me which is like music should the
actually say recorded music I believe
that is a case and I will ask mr. Malati
to just confirm that he does require
recorded music to be included within the
application consideration thank you 20 J
it does say supply of alcohol does say
not applicable and it is not required
and confusing on that one because on the
boxes on the premises off the premises
both it doesn't seem to say anything at
all some were just a bit confused on
that on that particular page yes to
provide a little bit of clarity I did
pick up with mr. malossi after the
original application was submitted and I
provided clarity to responsible
authorities he did require the sell of
alcohol both on and off the premises in
relation to seasonal variations so for
example did he require any additional
sort of hours for Christmas Eve New
Year's Eve Valentine's he said not
clickable and again that follows on with
the non-standard times that he will
literally just be looking to keep to the
hours that are specified in the
left-hand column just terrified that I
think it was saying an extra hour
it was now on bank holidays 0.23 Carol
post 19 thank you yes it does actually
say on his opening hours but he unless
he stipulated in the times for the
actual sale of alcohol with any of the
boxes he's put na to any sort of
seasonal variation but I wonder whether
mr. malossi might want to clarify that
himself bear in mind he's he's present
with ourselves thank thank you microcosm
is there any question you'd like to ask
the green return I could share it not at
this time thank you very much no see can
you please present your submissions
sorry can you please elaborate on what
you required please yeah can you just so
the committee exactly your application
for requesting these times these further
leases yes that's absolutely fine
basically as you know the red door is
when establish venue in Breda High
Street we've been there for five years
now the issue we have every year is a
big burden on our resources as well as
the council's resources of having to
request temporary event notices for
additional hours changing basically the
license to be able to do what we need to
be doing we've do the same every single
year never have any objections against
any temporary event notice we've
required we're trying to streamline
things make things more straightforward
from the initial license that we put in
place five years ago through obviously
being a new venture in this sector
it was very vague in what I required for
the business but has obviously been in
his business for a long time now I am
working with other venues within Valley
High Street on how applications are done
and what licenses are what's needed on
the license for a business to run
smoothly and professionally this is why
now I found the time to put in the
amended well a new application to give
us the ability to run our business more
smoothly rather than having to keep
requesting permission to operate on
certain days it's just very back with
what we have now is very basic
the one we submit now is more advanced
is more clarity for security for
ourselves for the police when they visit
out venue because even with you know
experts by the police and licensing
department
it is quite confusing what we have right
now when we can operate and when we can
so we want to know black and white along
with all our staff if we have please
visit slicin visited visits it clearly
says what we can do rather than having
to sort of guests are we allowed to
operate on this day or not because that
is
what we've experienced over the years so
by doing this it does resolve all them
problems
thank you very much members of the
committee if you'd like to ask any
questions this moment I'm mr. mr. most
melissy counselor mr. Shaw I believe
you've got a couple of questions you'd
like to ask like a chair um couple
relate to the security personnel at the
moment they're only showing us Friday
and Saturday and I think it's down to
the DPS to decide if there's others
needed and one of the conditions that
the police put on or that we put on is
that nobody is allowed in there after
one o'clock how's this going to be
operated who's going to be you can have
people on the door to make sure no
becomes in our to those signs and why do
you feel that there's no these security
is not needed on other nights would you
like to answer the question mr. Massey
please yeah sure that's absolutely fine
thanks bring out to my attention first
of all security are on the door right up
until closed every single weekend
without fail so that is that point
covered the second one is why do we not
have security midweek hours the reason
being for that that's not a requirement
on our license secondly our venue does
not require security during those times
where we are the sort of venue we are
dozen how can I put it politely it
doesn't attract a clientele that causes
disruption within our venue that is just
how we operate the premises
you know the premises perceives that as
you walk in it this deters trouble .
we've had zero trouble midweek during
all the five years we've been operating
and it's really only weekend's that we
require security and that's not because
we have
trouble in our venue we just done don't
get me wrong from time to time we do
have the odd incident but it's minor and
asked me being honest with you where
there's alcohol there's always trouble
that is for same with any venue but we
have security purely to regulate numbers
to make sure that if there is something
there we've obviously got that presence
on the door and as I say it is a
requirement on our license to have
security
we're regionally when we applied for
this application five years ago I opted
not to have security being naive but
obviously looking out looking backwards
back at that it makes perfect sense for
us to have security on your date so all
their mouths are covered but midweek the
type of VIN we are family and kids in
there
it's a lovely environment it's just not
something we would entertain and less
there was going to be trouble calls then
obviously would really eight that a late
today and I know that the police would
also bring that to our attention as well
I hope that answers your question well
the only thing that I would add on that
is that we are now looking at extending
those hours you know we're looking up to
2:30 in the morning all right I totally
agree with you on that I can see where
you're coming from the thing is you know
as I've said to Stephen greener when we
applied for this license we would love
to be able to operate till six o'clock
in the morning if that was possible but
unfortunately railing is not that town
we are 30 40 50 years away from ever
having a town that's going to be that
busy and I really wish we did have that
in our town where we had that sort of
commerce available but unfortunately
Raley is a very quiet town and to be
honest with you most evenings at the
weekend
sorry most evenings of a midweek we're
closed probably by 10 11 o'clock the
latest there is just no clientele in the
town at that time and it's as simple as
that unfortunately that is the case and
saying does need to be done in our town
to sort of put it back on the map and
you know bring bring
money to our area so there is no concern
with that so I hope that answers your
question sorry sorry I just need a shim
please he'll help me please on the days
you haven't got any security then
considering you're saying that you
should pretend to finish at ten o'clock
maybe sometimes in the week and you want
to stay open till some to two thirty can
you just sort of give us an idea and the
security work on that side please yeah
that's absolutely fine well I must point
out the whole reason for us having this
transparent license is not that we want
to operate till half two in the morning
every single day of the week for one
financially that's not viable for us
because we don't have the customers to
be able to you know even serve in the
first place the whole reason behind this
is that where the current license we
have at the moment is all the dates that
we require I'm not on there this makes
it possible for special events dates
like Christmas New Year's Eve bank
holidays although I'm sort of things
where they change throughout every year
is different that's the only reason why
we asked for it and it cause there's a
lot of admin on both sides when other
venues in the high street have what
we're trying to apply for now already in
place and they don't have the stress
that it causes us when we need to do
like a last-minute panic for a temp
event notice for example so running to
them sort of ours doesn't it's not even
going to come to the equation security
for example if we was to have an event
take place which is rare then we would
evaluate it on the numbers that are
attending like we do for example on our
Friday Saturday's our current condition
is only requiring two security but for
example on nights where we know we're
going to have more demand or there's a
risk of trouble in the area where we've
been warmed we automatically add one two
or three even sniffer dogs on our doors
to deter now I don't know any other
venue within our area that operates like
that at all and that's what the red
dough is renowned for
I hope that answers your question Thank
You mr. Rossi can ask you a couple of
the questions regarding fire regulations
how many people are you allowed to have
in your pub at any one time and how do
you um how do you clarify that with
people come in and going our record our
capacity is believe it or not is around
about 250 to 270 we regulate that at
about hundreds slightly over just to
keep a comfortable atmosphere inside our
the local authority fire department have
come and done the risk assessment in our
premises they check everything every
year obviously those stats are when we
first opened and if we have any internal
changes then we liaise with them and say
you know obviously we've had you know
we've done some building work in there
or whatever then we contact them and
then it gets really know that I'm
purchased in the papers you said that
you want anybody in after 1 p.m.
how are you going to lease that how you
going to support people especially the
weekends I'm thinking all the fines and
Saturdays people coming in after 1 1
p.m. especially one popping they're
coming into yours that's fine our secure
even now where our licenses till 1
o'clock in the morning our security
employed till 1:30 and that's been I am
and that's been like that since day 1
for 5 years so it's just an extra half
an hour security required for moving
forward if this license is to be granted
thank you I think you want to ask a
couple questions but one question are
mr. Massey oh if your people are
drinking outside the glasses so they
have plastic are you using gas our
regulations on our license only permit
alcohol to be consumed up until 9
o'clock that
ties in with other venues in the high
street prior to that they are tempered
glass senior proof glasses they're not
plastic vessels it's one thing that we
specified from day one that we wouldn't
want in our venue is plastic because
unfortunately the clientele that we have
in our venue would simply not come they
would not drink out of a plastic glass
so this was st. we discussed years ago
and it was based on how we operated and
obviously if there was trouble then
obviously polycarbonate glasses would
have to be a requirement to this day we
haven't had any trouble that raises
concern and from our own risk
assessments plus from Odyssey on the
police side that has requested made it a
requirement for us to have plastic
glasses we just don't have that sort of
behavior and fingers crossed we van have
moved forward either thank you for the
clarification
oh yeah so mr. Shaw you want to ask a
question I believe Thank You chair yeah
it was a couple of things on one the the
music and the dance whatever you're
saying that goes up the musical play
till 2:30 is but time will so that means
people will be there to what time will
they actually be leaving if the music's
going on till 2:30 that's one thing and
also I think mr. greener we mentioned
earlier and we we need an answer with
one of the questions is state any
seasonal variations perform performance
of dance music the answer is not
applicable a non-standard timings where
you intend to use the premises the
performance at dance music non required
yet you're asking for bank holidays
Christmas whatever an extra hour will
surely you would need extensions on
these timings for that sort of thing to
happen
I can answer that for you that's
actually fine so first of all the music
and dance yes that will be taking place
at those times your concern is obviously
the noise and we totally understand that
I totally understand that now what we
have in place is quite a strict set of
terms that not many other venues have in
this town and obviously we're all here
to make sure that Raley remains a safe
place there's zero disruption you know
keep the peace that we have within this
town and I'm more than happy to work
with concerned parties within this
meeting after this meeting which would
really make a big difference in this
town with current procedures that are in
place in other venues which are far more
well very you know work does cause
problems that you don't want to happen
so first of all we have noise limiters
in place they are set by our sound
engineers who have also sent the
document which shows what they will set
out to environmental they have approved
them we take noise checks every weekend
at the front and at the rear of our
premises we've done that for five years
that's when we started no other venue
takes decibel readings at their venue
and records them down like we do now the
other thing is we have laminated glass
on the front of our venue seven point
two millimeters thick to be exact that
it was not a requirement but that
stomach we've done that environmental
are aware of that is a noise suppression
in itself our front door is off mahogany
that's a vent solid material it's not
made of a soft wood such as pine it's a
solid door that greatly reduces noise on
top of that my company which is a
building company installed nine and a
half thousand bricks in that building
so our venue is I building inside a
building no other venue
that they stick up wallpaper brick
effect that's not what we do we got nine
and a half thousand bricks in that venue
that line every single wall on top of
that the ceilings are all soundproof and
plaster boarded dive bar and plastered
on top obviously so that is our third
level of soundproofing there is no noise
noise disruption that comes from our
venue in terms of the music it does is
impossible the third one is the the
timings in which they're allowed to
dance - yes our license if this is
granted would be at two o'clock when
alcohol sales stop and then they have a
quiet drink up period - half 2:00 in the
morning that calms everyone down before
they leave they seasonal variation one
which you put forward to Stephen now the
reason why we haven't got anything in
that seasonal variation is the whole
reason for this application in the first
place it's to take out all of those
timings that cause problems that could
cause us to breach our license which we
do not want to do and again take away
the administration sides on our side and
on the council side to approve dates
that we have every single year time and
time again they're already approved what
we're asking for now is already been in
place for five years already all it's
doing is it's making it official with
less paperwork involved I hope that
answers your question thank you I think
your chair I'm still a bit confused
about um
other than the Friday this evening and
the other time but no you say you finish
it maybe 10:00 10:30
my concern is about having security on
the doors and the other question I will
ask is on the days where you're saying
about dancing etc music and dance
is that going to operate too hard pass
three on public holidays your first
question with regards to the security
midweek as I say that gets evaluated if
for example we was to have a request to
have I don't know awake there or some
sort of professional function that was a
mixture of children adults or depending
on sort of the event that was going to
take place then that something that we
automatically put out to the person
enquiring is that security will be
provided
now that doesn't come to an expense at
us that gets added on to their on to
their quote as such so it doesn't it's
not us trying to avoid you know any
expense or anything if we need security
in that place we will have it it's as
simple as that and midweek we have a
lovely family environment it's like
requesting a like for example a for
example a harvest or another chained
establishment so have security we are
not a pub we are a high-end bar our
clients don't behave rationally it just
doesn't happen in our venue it is I
don't know if any of you've been there
or not but obviously I don't go on about
too much but we do not attract trouble
in our venue it's as simple as that we
are fortunate to be that high-end bar
not a pub sort of atmosphere I believe
that was all your questions answered
music dance music and dance we are
Friday on Saturday venue for that
midweek
they have again the only time that that
would take place is if for example it's
a bank holiday Monday or Easter Sunday
or something like that on a special
event other than that if for example we
was to have a birthday party or
something like that which is rare then
obviously we would have music but very
unlikely to that's all the time okay I'm
sorry I'm gonna go back again and I'm
still concerned about this midweek
people coming in at
one o'clock one fine it kind of what
you're going to place that if you know
like I know there's another thing I want
to ask you about sees them they're like
having a refusal book is maintained I
mean not gonna have anybody on the door
how's that going to work as well the
first one is we will not be staying open
so anywhere near them sort of times as a
general sort of everyday the trading day
there's just no demand for it in our
town at all and one it's just
financially not buy recalled for us and
really we don't want to be open to that
late anyway the second one with the
refusal but well paperwork is something
I'm very proud of and the local
licensing authority the police know that
as well we have so much paperwork
policies procedures compliance protocol
sheets in place now we have multiple
refusal books we don't just have like a
basic one that most venues have we have
quite advanced one so we have one for
our security that if anything incident
takes place we've been out venue they
fit in that one they also have their own
supplied one because our security is
outsourced they fill in that one as well
then our staff ourselves our great team
that work there they also have their own
refusal logbook that they have in there
now that records down for example any
refusal logs of underage people that
come in not saying we have to do but
we've been told it's the best thing to
do so we can lock that down so for
example if stomach was to come back on
us we could say actually on this day
person of this description was noted
down and they were refused not served
today over the five years we haven't had
one incident with underage serving or
any other incident like that Thank You
counselors mr. Shaw mr. Shaw is there
any other questions you'd like to ask at
all no thank you
no thank you mr. green ot questions
you'd like to ask it's all of these okay
check could I just ask question on my
members yes of course
and then maybe chair you you may
actually want to
questioner I think one thing that you
want it clarifying was on the days when
there's no one on the door who is going
to police the one p.m. late entrance I
think that's something you wanted to
clarify isn't it chair thank you
the reason why we have that 1:00 p.m.
restriction is basically when other
venues in the town are open to that time
there's a high chance that patrons are
intoxicated that point what we don't
want to do is then invite them into our
venue and increase further drinking to
already very intoxicated people
customers so that's why we have that one
o'clock and that works fantastically
with us because what we don't want is is
other we don't want drunk people coming
in at that time you know we're trying to
one things down at there but that's all
point in time so that is the reason why
this is whole one o'clock thing how we
regulate that is very simple if someone
if we were to be open at that's all the
time anyway
midweek which is very rare let me make
that clear then it's a very simple job
of our staff on shift saying sorry we do
not serve past one o'clock chair I think
that the query was in terms of the door
who's going to stop people coming in if
there's no one on the door that's the
question isn't it yes that would be our
staff on shift chair are you happy with
that response
yes mr. greener did you want to ask you
have to put any questions at all so you
you muted mr. greevy story no nothing
from the licensing team thank you okay
councillor mr. Wilkinson is it you'd
like to ask yet become please I could
share and obviously I've got so
submission of my own but I would like to
ask the applicant one quick questions
okay could you just explain to the
committee
what engagement if any you've had with
the residents
and worked with them with regardless
application people who live above you
yes sure
today we haven't had the best of my
knowledge that saying environmental
would be out to water precisely is that
from my knowledge we haven't had any
complaints from tenants in that facility
of our building the reason being is that
when the Red Door was built there five
years ago there was no tenants there at
all it was just an office block and
their landlords who owned this block
from the police station right up to
Iceland haven't built any dwellings
livable dwellings there for that
particular reason
no premises no dwelling is above our
venue or to the site for that reason
because they know that our business
operates there sorry yeah so my question
was not have you are your webbing to
complaints its what have you done to
engage with the residents who live up
there in preparation for this
application well it's very
straightforward if we have any
representations from environmental which
we haven't there would be the first one
to bring it to our attention when it's
brought to our attention then what we do
with that is then obviously because
environmental very strict if there's a
problem they will make sure that we deal
with it so at the moment we haven't had
anything okay all right that's okay so
you haven't done any okay Thank You
chair are any more questions from the
committee
regarding regarding this one o'clock I
completely understand that you're not
gonna have security and the bar staff
will stop anyone coming in how how do
you know they're new people coming in if
they're just standing out yeah might be
concerned if they come up across from
the robots or somewhere how will you
know they're not just normal regulars
that you've had in before how home that
be pleased thank you for bringing that I
was hoping song with
so that the reason being is is that
we're not a busy venue midweek the
majority of our customers you know have
to be up early the next day to go to
work like I say we're not a pub we're a
high-end bar our numbers are very
minimal during midweek so as soon as
someone enters they stick out like a
sore thumb our staff will be a media be
able to tell that they are new customers
or existing customers and we will not be
open till that time and if we are going
to be open or that's all the time the
high chances it's on a special day like
as I say bank holiday Easter Sunday all
those sort of dates and security will be
on the door then because we will not
operate without them thank you does
anybody else want to ask any questions
at all at all members or counsel might
Wilkinson do you want to ask any more
questions at all
No thank you check a closing statement
mr. greener do you want to do a cozy
space yeah chair poetry's I do have a
submission of my owner which I'd like to
read out but on behalf of the local
residents I wasn't sure if that's what
you were alluding to when you gave me
the opportunity to ask mr. velocity
questions I'm sure that's fine as okay
yeah and chair the questions from
Council Wilkinson were fine and they
form part of essentially the applicants
part to speak so yeah now the chance to
speak now part is over to the interested
party which is in this case council
Wilkinson and then not asleep other
parties can then ask him any questions
as has been carried on with the other so
far thank you yes sorry carry on thank
you very much chairman members I'm
attending this meeting today is one of
the ward councillors for the ward in
which the Red Door is situated the red
doors a relatively small establishment
which is situated in the high street a
few doors up from the police station
there are retail units either side and
opposite and above around along that
line of shops there are residential
flats some which single parents are in
some of the early residence
you there's only been two objections
raised on the online system however I
have had a number of residents have
contacted me directly as the ward counts
that having put feelers out to try and
attract interested representations and
it's those people I'm representing today
I have concerns about the hours which
the applicants are suggesting you to
consider as appropriate historically
licensed premises closed their doors by
11:00 or 11:30 in actual fact mr.
molasses that he usually closes his by
about 10:30 to 11:00 obviously the
obvious exception of Friday yet this
applicant is asking you to permit his
business to remain open until the early
hours of the morning had passed to the
applicant has submitted that this is to
prevent requesting temporary event
notices every other licensed premises
managers to do this in addition this
reaffirms that the applicant is seeking
essentially what equates to 24/7
licensing hours which equate to what
other premises may be may require four
or five times a year what I mean by that
is and where most licensed premises may
require special event notice four or
five times a year for something like New
Year's Eve or something like that they
applied for attempt event notices and
what this application is trying to seek
is to have that special exemption every
single day of the year once granted if
granted there will be every possibility
that the red door be able to remain open
till 2:30 every day even if they don't
want to even if they're saying they
don't want to that is the legally the
possibility that they will have that's
not what they intend to do then why
apply for it I accept mr. Mallinson may
consider the times appropriate due to
the premises location of high street and
it being away from the main residential
area of the town however there aren't
residential units above the occupants of
those units are entitled to rest peace
and quiet and the ability to sleep at
night I would respectfully suggest as
allowing a bar to remain open so late
every night of the week every week of
the year which essentially this
application if granted will allow them
to do directly so directly below this
residence is going to totally ruin their
lives and privacy for those residents
concerned chairman my second concern is
regarding the possibility
advantage social behavior and violent
disorder and I share some of the
concerns raised by your members this
afternoon the applicants are suggesting
the use of door staff and Friday and
Saturday but not every other day of the
week even though the opening hours
essentially remain the same if he does
not expect customers to be in the bar
until early hours on Saturday Thursday
such as door staff are not needed then
why asked for these hours and the
applicant in the application I mean
total favor of supporting local
businesses and I'm very mindful of the
difficult tons faced by the hospitality
industry recently having only been
allowed to open their doors two days ago
without a door a sight bigger pardon two
days ago but to allow this premises to
keep its doors open until the early
hours of the morning every day without
any door staff for five out of the seven
nights is simply a recipe for disaster
Essex Police is situated only three or
four doors away however the mere fact
that a licensed premises is situated so
close to a police station there's not
permitted to push the boundaries on
understanding that if it all goes wrong
it won't take long for the police to
respond I'm also mindful there's a large
number of conditions have been suggested
on the license extension if it's granted
these are going to involve a huge amount
of policing to ensure the license that
either here's to them on behalf of the
council and Essex Police and I'm not
convinced that form honest with you
chairman that either watch your district
council or Essex police have got the
resources to effectively police these
conditions on a regular basis and I use
the phrase regular basis deliberately as
this is what will be required rather
than once a year or something similar
chairman in summary in view of the
concerns raised about the inability to
properly police the conditions the
strong possibility of disorder at the
premises and moreover moreover the
negative effect this extension will have
on the lives of those who live above
plus the clear lack of need for this
extension an admission from the
applicants itself he used the words very
rare repeatedly I urge you all please to
dismiss this application thank you Joe
listen and that's the green ax did you
want to do your closing statement please
chair sorry did you want to ask just the
other parties if they have any questions
for mr. Wilkinson councillor Wilkinson
at all
engine councillors sure mrs. sure did
you want to ask council Wilkinson any
questions no I have no questions thank
you very much
that's where mr. Shaw at all well thank
you a chair and mr. Melissa unless did
you want to ask a counselor Wilkinson
any questions at all on his statement
yes I would love to be able to respond
it's really refreshing and I don't mean
this in a patronizing way at all to have
a counter that genuinely is keen to make
sure this town you know is a good town
that operates professionally zero
disruption it's very fun very rare to
come across people that like myself that
want them sort of that sort of
environment my environment maintained I
would like to be able to meet up at some
point and discuss other issues in this
town that would actually make a big
difference and if we can arrange saying
laughter that would be fantastic but
response to your questions that you put
forward your statement they're not
things that I'm not going to respond to
me because I'm too keen for this
application to get passed I actually
want to highlight and elaborate on what
you've put forward to me because it's
what I want to do is make sure after
this meeting whatever way whatever
decision is made is that it's very clear
that the business I'll pray and any
other business that I own operate is run
very professionally and that is what I
pride myself on now the residents above
if they have a problem we would have had
environmental knocking on our door
long time ago and bringing this to our
attention we haven't had that or that
hasn't happened so I don't know where
these are coming from if they are
actually in the vicinity or they are you
know down the road which could be any
pub causing that sort of disruption or
bar and how we're going to maintain our
procedures and all that well we can
maintain them very well we've
demonstrated that for five years and yes
you are right in saying that you know we
could abuse these hours till half 2:00
in the morning we say we don't need them
now and yet tomorrow if this was granted
we could go ahead and do that but like
you said we have many many restrictions
on our licence and if we breach those
that will cost our business so it's not
in our interest to say one thing and do
another because we've got a very popular
famous establishment there that brings a
lot of joy to a lot of local residents
for families and we demonstrate put it
like this the other venues in our town
they use us an example
whatever we do they do whatever we do
first they end up doing if we bring out
a new idea or something that comes
across very professional or something
like that you can guarantee within 24
hours they are doing it in effect we do
inspire other venues now I don't need to
come across big-headed like that but we
work very hard to make sure that we are
spot-on
every single time and we demonstrated
that over five years with the the
minimal trouble that we've had in our
place the minimal dealings that we've
had with environmental with our venue we
just don't have trouble at our venue yes
we do from time to time minor things but
we don't have people with axes trying to
knock down front doors of venues we
don't have women with metal bars in
their hand like other putts do we just
don't entertain that sort of trouble
we risk no additional behaved crime and
disorder to this town that's all if
anything we reduce it by having the type
of procedures we have in place but if
there's general concerns you know in
this town like you're saying that our
venue may but may cause well I can be
honest with you there's already venues
in this town that create that and
nothing's been done today and with this
issue of not having security on our door
well a recent license application has
been recently submitted well yes and
approved and though obviously is in in
Fault right now where it is purely a
drinking establishment and yet no
security is required on their license
yet every other venue in our town has to
have security and it's a financial cost
that a lot of us don't want to have but
being a professional business we realize
that we need that and we wouldn't dream
of operating without security how is
this new application gone through on
another venue in Raley no security so if
it's a genuine concern where trouble
doesn't what you know you don't want
trouble in this town I would really
focus on those venues and that is where
I can help you I can work with you and I
can help you reduce crime and disorder
and also at the same time make sure that
licenses are transparent so whether
we're big small or medium-sized
businesses
we all have exactly the same regulations
on our restrictions on our licenses and
we have the same policing approach to it
so it's mr. policy sorry this sounds
more like a closing statement rather an
answer yes I apologize but as I say me I
take pride in our town hence why I put a
beautiful bar here and I want to you
know it's fantastic to hear someone that
wants to continue that so sorry for
going on but I do get better no that's
fine
Council welcome Susan he or she wants
you to
societal yeah just just come back very
briefly if I made then I'll finish and
and just director mister mister velocity
thank you for for what you say the with
regards to the complaints it's not
unusual and in fact this has happened to
me a couple of times before where
residents have come to me directly it's
a sort of relationship that we as counts
there's no I'm sure I speak for all
members of the sitting looking at me
right now that we do with our residents
that we we create relationships where
they come to us and that's what our job
of war counselor is and the fact that
nobody's been to environmental health
directly it's not indicative of a lack
of an issue it just means to say that
they would rather speak to their world
counts that than go straight to the
council which is what's happened in this
case and and I have no doubt about and I
don't wish to disrespect your
professionalism or anything at all but
and obviously you know and I've got no
evidence to disprove anything you've
said but what I would remind members of
course is that there's nobody here to to
dispute it and decided actually mister
mister loss is not saying you know he's
not the the best premises in you know
the town so but no I have nothing
further to say on this sir thank you
very much thank you very much um sorry
mr. greener do you want to do your
closing statement Thank You mr. Massey
if you want to do anything else with
your closing statements you that you've
already seen that you'll reach someone
but is there anything else that you'd
like to add at all sorry
no there isn't at all no I think that's
it I think the committee will now
adjourn I've been listened to all the
information today by counselors and
other parties sorry chair yes sorry mr.
confirm does counsel Wilkinson have a
closing speech as as it were thank you
mister Thank You chair
no no I'm I think I've said enough thank
you
thank you thank you right so that
committee will now adjourn to consider
the case we will return in approximately
an hour to announce the decision this
will also be sent to you in writing you
don't have to wait but obviously you're
welcome to do to do so and so in the
meantime we will leave this meeting and
return on the next nice dream check
check and I just saw just work from a
practical point of view perhaps Tony
could answer this what are we all going
to leave the meeting then read login on
the same details again we are know the
details different ascent out there there
should there a separate joining
instructions there for a separate
session okay sorry sorry counsel
focusing and okay that's fine so we will
be seeing you in about about an hour's
time members thank you